hi there this is uh steve kaufman uh
i normally talk mostly about language
learning a little bit about education
and i'd like to talk a little bit today
about the importance of reading in
education
i came across an item on the internet
entitled academically adrift
and it was a study which showed
that 45 percent of students in
universities in the united states did
not demonstrate any significant
improvement in learning
during their first two years of college
36 percent of students did not
demonstrate any significant improvement
over four years of college and if we go
through this and even students who
improved improved on average only 0.18
standard deviations blah blah blah i
don't want i don't understand what all
of that means but they didn't improve
very much and as you read through the
article and i will try because you can't
post a link on youtube but i'll i'll
post it on my blog the linguist on
language
but you read through the article and it
really boils down to those courses where
students are asked to or forced to read
a lot they improve
and those courses where they don't read
so much they don't improve that to me
seems to be the bottom line here
so that was one article i should point
out by the way that um
i remember when i was at mcgill
university in my first year
the chancellor stood up and spoke to the
first year students and told them to
look at the fellow on the right or the
girl on the right and the person or the
person on the right the person on the
left
and one of them won't be here next year
because the first year one-third of
people fail out
so that's another thing about
universities a lot of people go there
probably without too clear of an idea
why they're there and a high percentage
of them fail out
given that universities cost
an awful lot of money i mean the average
cost for a university student
is something like
two or three times the cost of a student
in the regular school system
uh depending on where you are it's 20 30
40 000
of which the student pays a certain
amount themselves
but most of it is paid for by the
taxpayer or by in the case of private
universities if they have
scholarship funds i mean very often it's
paid by someone else or the parent
so one-third fail out those that stay
behind don't learn very much that's
really not very encouraging and the key
to
improving your learning is to read
so then
why does the university matter why don't
people just read more
uh
you know that would cost it wouldn't
cost thirty thousand dollars a year
uh
get yourself a reading list on subjects
that are of interest to you now of
course i know the answer
the answer is that people need the
ticket that the university provides
because that's some kind of a ticket to
a better job
and other people say that there's all
the interaction and and of course uh
stimulus and so forth yeah but according
to these statistics 30 40 of the
students don't learn very much so how
much stimulus is there at the university
i don't know
there was another series of articles in
canada
about an academic sort of
watchdog
canadian
group of of university professors who
were going around investigating the
religious based universities
and their view was that a university
that required you to
make some statement or commitment about
your faith or your belief your belief in
certain religious
uh dogma
therefore made the university less of a
of a place where free you know
academic activities could be
pursued
and i'm sure that's true to some extent
however
um if we bear in mind that many
universities in the world were started
as religious institutions
if we consider the degree to which
political correctness correctness
dominates our universities
uh i'm not convinced
that there is in fact less opportunity
for learning
at these religious institutions
besides which
if the main thing is how much you read
then it's really up to the student how
much they choose to read and no one can
prevent a student from reading whatever
they want to read
and if the main real reason why people
go to universities is to get a ticket
then you know if if i add to a job
then
you know if i'm an employer and i have a
student who graduated from the uh
you know holy cross seminary or from the
uh you know uh
some kind of a muslim or sikh or jewish
or buddhist
institution uh if i want that to
influence you know the validity that i
uh ascribe to that diploma well that'll
be my choice
so um
yeah i i don't think this this
group of professors should be out there
saying that this university because it's
a religious
institution therefore is less valid
um
i think it's going to be up to the
students as to what they make of it of
course the professors do influence the
students
uh and and that's also kind of
unfortunate uh we see that in our
mainstream universities where there's
this very you know anti-establishment
really anti-capitalist
anti-profit
all the things that pay for the
university
uh ideology
uh these students are there paying three
five thousand dollars a year
uh when the true cost is 30 000 they
feel that they should have to pay less
that everything should be provided for
them and they want to basically beat up
on the system that provides that pays
the taxes that pays for the universities
so and of course the professors are very
much involved with with uh
fomenting this kind of attitude so
you know i guess the the point of of all
of this is
um
how much you learn whether at a
university or not at a university
is largely dependent on how motivated
you are to read or nowadays on the
internet to access
people
videos other sources of knowledge about
the subject you're interested in
and i'm referring primarily to the
humanities to to
history literature languages uh
things of this nature
but let's not forget
that there are i think it's only 12
of students who study the hard subjects
you know math science engineering
and there i think the state should pick
up the tab because obviously for any
certainly developed economy that that
wants to be an innovative economy and a
competitive economy they need people
with those kinds of skills so there i
think the state should pick up more of
the tab but when it comes to the
humanities which is largely a matter of
reading because the reading will not
only enable you to access so much
knowledge
uh it's also going to improve your
ability to communicate which is
extremely important it's interesting in
this article now that i remember it they
found that students who study on their
own learn more
students who spend most of their time
studying in groups don't learn very much
i've always felt that i've never quite
understood this desire to get people
together in groups to learn
you kind of have to sit down with the
book and read
and in the case of language learning
i've always felt
that
the time that i spend listening and
reading on my own is much more valuable
and much more efficient
uh than time that i spend with other
learners
so i mean you know my bent on this i'm
very much of a of an in pro independent
learning uh and and particularly if i'm
paying for it
somehow in there we should be
encouraging people to read more
and and making people more responsible
for their own learning so there you have
it a little bit of a departure from from
the language learning stuff
and i look forward to
your comments thank you for listening